we're going to need all the help we can
get let's get to work call dark and
horny at
12:00 I've been waiting 40 years for
this they called themselves Ghostbusters
according to these hacks they saved the
world no
eyewitnesses and who is found to carry
the torch descendants of Egon
Spangler you have a minor hanging out
the side of a moving vehicle fire weing
a laser gun indiscriminately has a
proton pack it's completely safe I
wouldn't say completely safe the
Ghostbusters are finished right well
overruled
sustained thank
you you the weird guy who buys strange
old things correct on both counts buddy
you just hit the
jackpot what is it better question is
what's inside of
it
The Parables tell of an unimaginable
evil commanding an Army of
Ghosts that's the power to kill by fear
itself like literally scared to
[Music]
death we might be looking at our second
Ice
Age we're going to need all the help we
can get let's get to
work can I be of any help melet in un
form
yeah is there something
strange there's something weird what are
people going to call Ghostbusters what
do you
[Music]
want we're the Ghostbusters can I tell
you something else what Buster makes me
feel good makes me feel
good
[Music]
heads up it's all dark and horny at
12:00 yeah
[Music]